[Music]
hey you guys
what's going on
i swear to god i can't do a literal
single thing without him laughing at me
or making fun of me for some reason
why he was you're making me like so
self-conscious like i can't even talk or
anything because he's like no for some
reason it's funny even though i'm just
being normal i don't really understand
like what your [ __ ] deal is no it was
just i thought it was just a funny intro
it's not a funny intro it's the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] i talk like all the time
okay it's like why is the camera so
weird i'm trying to get like okay i was
just trying to get a [ __ ] spock in
there this yeah we're gonna talk about
uh house of the clock on its walls this
jenny read this one uh when he was when
she was a kid in the book i saw it i saw
the book i never read it
when i was a kid you know what i mean
they had it at the library
i remember like in the third grade but
the movie was pretty good we probably
can't do a real long show though because
um
we gotta go see dude yeah we're gonna go
see dune and we have to leave at
probably like 3 30. yeah so probably
like half an hour we have to keep this
one kind of and i'm gonna say too that
it's like i'm pretty sure
that because house with a clock and its
walls came out in 2018 so i'm pretty
sure i mean i know we saw it in the
theater because we had the amc [ __ ] back
then
and um so we probably did cover this or
review it like after we saw in the movie
but that i think that was before we were
doing like the live stream format so we
probably just like recorded like a five
minute reaction to it and it's just you
know what i mean so i feel like it was a
long time ago um so i was kind of like
well i don't know if i want to redo the
same movie again but then i was like
then again
um you know i just bought it like
because they had the dvd for really
cheap at fye and i was like and i kind
of wanted to rewatch it uh and see if i
liked it as much the second time so we
just like watched it last cuz i was kind
of in the mood to watch it last night
because it's kind of even though it's
not really said at halloween it is kind
of like a halloweeny type
vibe of a movie you know what i mean it
has kind of like that goosebumps
kind of [ __ ] too better i kind of feel
like yeah it's not quite as juvenile
there is like some kind of juvenile
things in it but it's not quite as
it's at the same level like like maybe
like harry potter
yeah and it it's it's weird because i
was kind of like reading some reviews of
this and i was thinking if you didn't
know that this was based on like an old
novel
from 1973
you could be forgiven for thinking oh
it's just like another cash-in
of all you know kind of the y-a fantasy
stuff that came in you know harry potter
and then the wake of it but i was like
but the book of this
was actually like way older like
pre-predates harry potter by quite a
significant margin the harry potter
stuff was probably ripping this off
well i mean i don't even know if it was
ripping it off because i i kind of feel
like this is a pretty common trope in
why a fantasy and was even back in the
day when john bel airs first wrote the
novel and honestly this is not just one
novel it's a whole series
and i think initially when i read them
because i read i read the first three
and i actually have the first three they
actually a couple years back they put
all three of the the first uh trilogy in
like one big hardback and i have that
but i think that there were um there
ended up being 12 books about this kid
about louis barneville which i actually
didn't even realize
um the first book the house for the
clock and its walls was
i mean that was easily my favorite book
growing up i must have read it 40
bajillion times and i think one of the
things i liked about it i just liked the
whole vibe of it it was just like this
really creepy
i liked it because
it was set back in the 50s and so and it
just had this really gothic sort of
sensibility to it it wasn't super over
the top or wacky or anything like that
it just had like really creepy low-key
kind of mystery element to it and i
think another thing that helped a lot
was that edward gory did the
illustrations like for the main and so i
kind of feel like i read the the two
subsequent ones which were good but i
didn't like them as much as the first
one i mean the first one when i read
that as a kid i was like i want to live
in this book you know what i mean just
the whole like atmosphere of it was just
magical to me i just loved all the
description of the house and everything
and so for a long time and i think i
wrote like a something on my blog a long
time ago about this because i was kind
of like look this book came out in 1973
when i was one
you know and then i probably read it the
first time when i was i don't know maybe
seven or eight years old and i [ __ ]
adored it and then as i got older and
especially after harry potter was this
massive success and they started making
all these moves like you know percy
jackson or whatever you know and a lot
of the other uh franchises i was like
why has nobody made a movie out of house
with a clock in its walls because one
that's like a whole series also and that
would be awesome
and it amazed me that it took until 2018
i think this is the only john bel airs
book that's been made into a movie at
this point which is mind-blowing to me
because i could i mean the the book and
it wasn't just me it was like it was a
really really popular book when i was a
kid it won i think it won a newbery
medal and like all kind of stuff so it
was definitely one that a lot of kids
read and a lot of kids were really into
it and so it just amazed me that it took
that long i think it had been in sort of
like production hell for a really long
time
um you know or development hell i mean
and uh so that's why it took so long and
so i mean when we went to see this in
the theater i had like really really
high expectations because i was like man
i've been waiting for years for some
[ __ ] to like make this into a movie
and finally somebody did and it's like i
you know the movie came out really good
i thought it's not you know it's
there's a lot of stuff that they could
have put in the movie that was in the
book that i think would have made it
cooler
but
i mean it's a pretty solid effort i
gotta say and i had forgotten again that
eli roth
directed this eli roth who also directed
hostile
and the green inferno the cannibal movie
and like all those like you know
obviously he's just known for doing
horror right and uh the fact that he
was able to do a movie like this which
is kind of like a throwback
to the old days like the 80s of like a
horror movie but for kids
yeah you know there's a lot of horror
elements yeah like you know like
gremlins or goonies or something like
that where there's like scary [ __ ] in it
but it's still like a kids movie
ghostbusters about that
yeah that kind of stuff that kind of
stuff you were in it
yeah so that's one of the things that um
i think that i kind of wish that they
hadn't put i know why they put it in
there like they have some kind of like
you know poop humor there's like like a
you know the like the pooping
uh lion hedge or whatever yeah like
that's kind of a repeating thing which
you know fine uh i get that kids like
poop jokes and farting and stuff so it's
like that's funny um that that wasn't in
the book i honestly i don't even think
[ __ ] was there even a lion i don't
remember there being like a lion out in
the garden i remember there being like a
really cool garden with the
with the uh you know what do they call
that thing they like the bird bath with
the moon and everything but yeah i don't
know what you call it i don't think that
um
no birdbath i said it birdbath
poop and fart jokes yeah it's like that
was so i kind of feel like they could
have done without that because the thing
that i always liked about this book and
i think that they really did kind of
capture some of this in the movie was
that
it was i guess because it was set in the
50s and it had kind of a gothic
sensibility so it was kind of like
classy
so i kind of feel like putting the poop
and fart stuff in there was just kind of
like it was a little tonally off to me i
didn't really notice it because it
wasn't real
it was a hedge animal yeah it was it
wasn't [ __ ] it was just a bunch of brown
leaves
that came out of his butt yeah
so i didn't really think i didn't really
consider it to be [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] jokes
yeah well i mean but that's what they're
supposed to be yeah that's what they
have but like i said little kids like
that kind of stuff
um but yeah so there but honestly i
think that
even though i don't know i was i was
trying to think to myself while i was
watching it last night i was kind of
like if i
was making this into a movie like during
you know the modern era i'm i'm not sure
if i would have thought
of jack black playing uncle jonathan
but watching it i was like yeah i think
he was probably a really good choice
because i guess i don't know like in my
mind i always kind of thought of uncle
jonathan from the book i guess because
of edward gory's drawings and stuff like
that as i almost kind of thought of him
as like bob ross but a little bit
chunkier and with a big huge like zz top
beard i kind of thought of him like that
that's a little bit like how edward
gorey drew him
um but jack black actually did a good
job he captured a lot of that kind of
like
he's an adult but he's kind of like this
whimsical and he has like a little bit
of a sinister thing too but not really
like he's like kind of charming but he's
also kind of like
like wacky i had no connection
to the movie or anything at all i just
watched it for what it was
and i like i like
some of jack black stuff you know i mean
so i just saw it i just watched it as a
jack black movie and i liked it just on
that level he was in goosebumps too yeah
i'm thinking about it yeah now i didn't
see the first one i think we saw
goosebumps too
what the [ __ ] it had a it had a a second
tell like a subtitle goosebumps to
electric boogaloo it wasn't that but i
remember we saw that in the theater and
jack black was in that too but i think
he was only in it a little bit but i
think that he was in the first one like
more
but
i didn't see the first one i should
probably i don't know it's i never
really got into the goosebumps stuff i
just i guess just because that's more a
90s kid thing and i was kind of more a
70s and 80s kid
so
that was more like when my sister was
younger she was like reading the
goosebumps books and stuff you know my
younger sister so i kind of feel like i
didn't have the same connection to those
but you know they're they're still good
and everything but i have to say another
thing they changed from the book was
that
in the book lewis the the main kid was
actually kind of like um
real uh
overweight like not like not super super
fat but he was just like you know chubby
and that was kind of one thing they did
kind of actually make him very
unathletic in the movie which you know
that was uh also in the book like he was
a very bookish kid and he couldn't play
sports and stuff but in the book he was
also like kind of chubby and they kind
of
uh brought that up a lot of times and i
will say too that cate blanchett was
absolutely
really really good as mrs zimmerman i
really really liked her
i think when i was reading the book i
can i thought of her as like a really
old woman
but
you know which obviously cate blanchett
isn't that old but i think she really
kind of sold it and also again she kind
of classed up the joint
a little bit
um
my favorite thing about this is the
production design
the inside of that house looks
amazing yeah and that's exactly how i
pictured it when i was reading the book
the strong points of the movie is that
it's a solid production
it's it's got good special effects it's
got real solid storytelling
and it's kind of like
fun for the whole family i wouldn't
really call it a kids movie
it's kids would like it and adults could
tolerate it you know because you got to
take the kids to the movie
and you can enjoy it because there's
there's some adult stuff that was kind
of snuck in there you know what i mean
you can you
i don't want to say innuendos but
some stuff you can read between the
lines i i think yeah just was kind of
like adult humor in there a kid probably
wouldn't pick up on it though i don't
remember exactly what it was though
and there is kind of and i think i said
this the first time that we saw it in
the theater was that i really hope that
this sort of heralds
because you know i feel like the 80s was
kind of like the heyday of like i said
family-friendly movies that were still
kind of scary yeah and kids love that
[ __ ] i mean i love that [ __ ] most kids
love that [ __ ] yeah it had some good
horror elements to it
you know what i mean like the bad guy
he's like a
it's like a lich i guess
yeah well he's an evil wizard and he
gets brought back from the dead i think
that would be so yeah there's some
necromancy going on in this [ __ ] too
yeah uh kyle mclaughlin plays him yeah i
had forgotten one thing that i wish they
had done more i wish they had done more
with kyle mclaughlin like because he's
great like as the villain he's you know
he's like an evil wizard that died and
then lewis uh sort of accidentally like
brings him back from the dead and it's
kind of like i don't know if this is
really that clear in the movie but
in the book
lewis didn't know that he was bringing
the evil wizard back from and i'm pretty
sure he didn't know in the movie either
he was just trying to bring somebody
back from the dead so he could show his
friend tarby how cool he was because
he's like look i can do necromancy and i
can bring somebody back from the dead
and he just picked
like a tomb
at random because it had a neat symbol
on it which was like an omega when he
didn't know what that was
and so he just went there and did the
spell not realizing that it was uh the
evil wizard who had owned the house
previously and then put the clock in
there i think too like in the book and i
guess i can see why they did this from
the movie but in the book the inside of
the house like wasn't all
clockwork because i feel like they do
like that big clockwork thing where at
the end and they have to like put the
thing in it to stop it in the book i'm
pretty sure it was just a regular clock
it was just like magically
hid somewhere so they couldn't find it
and it was counting down to doomsday
that's why they had to find it because
if they didn't find it then the world
was gonna end i think they added the
stuff about
um
about isaac being in the war and like
wanting to wipe the earth clean and all
that kind of stuff i don't remember that
being in the book so that might have
been like an additional backstory but i
kind of wish that they had
brought isaac back earlier in the film
and had him do more [ __ ] because i
remember very clearly in the book there
was a great scene
where
um jonathan and florence and louis are
driving back from somewhere like they go
out to dinner or something like that and
they're driving back and there's a car
like chasing them and there's a thing
where
and they do this a little bit in the
movie where isaac has these little round
spectacles and then there's always like
this you know like light on them so it
looks like these creepy eyes
and so and so there was like this car
chasing them and there's like a really
good scene in the book where there's
like this really really scary car chase
in the middle of the night with they're
pretty sure the wizard or agents of the
wizard like chasing them and it's really
really good and they didn't really put
that in the movie which is kind of a
shame um but so i kind of wish they had
that they had brought him back like
earlier on in the movie so they could do
more with him because he was a great
character um but the thing about it is
that i'm pretty sure this movie actually
did really well i think it made like 130
million dollars or something it was like
the top one the week it came out so i'm
imagining that eventually they will
probably make at least the first trilogy
because they did introduce
um
what's-her-face uh
[ __ ] what's that little girl's name rose
something
rose something um who was kind of a big
player in the second book like her and
louis like team up like on their next
mystery um and then like i said it goes
on to like a dozen books i think it was
but they do introduce her at the end of
this is like him making friends with her
uh because she's into the same nerdy
[ __ ] that he's into and so i feel like
they're gonna go that route and i
imagine they probably will because like
i said it made a lot of money
yuri said the movie was dull i don't
believe the movie was dull especially
not compared to the other [ __ ] that was
happening
that weekend i mean honest like i said
honestly i kind of liked and they added
some kind of harry pottery stuff to it
like um you know there is like a lot of
magic in the book and the kid is
learning to use magic
um but you know obviously they had to
put like cgi and special effects and
stuff like that in the in the book and
they kind of like had to
pump that up
but i kind of like that they retained a
lot of this sort of like classy
um sort of vibe of the novel because the
novel has a lot of fantasy [ __ ] in it
but it's not like roll over the top
oh another thing that i wish they had
kind of put in is that i know i don't
know if this really has much to do with
like the main story so that's probably
why they cut it out but in the book also
jonathan had this
um
kind of like a telescope kind of thing
or like that thing the scope like you
have on a ship or something like that
and he had that and you could look
through it and you could see anything
from history that you wanted to see like
a sextant yeah i think yes i think it
was something like that i mean i think
they but um and there's kind of like a
really cool sequence where lewis is in
there like watching this old like battle
or something it was like the spanish
armada or whatever and um so like i said
i don't know if that had anything to do
with like the overarching story but it
was just kind of like it kind of went
into this whole atmosphere of like this
little kid who's just lost his parents
and he's set to live with his relative
who he's never met before and then all
of a sudden it turns out that his
relative is actually like a warlock
and the neighbor is a witch and the
house is like magical like it has kind
of like all these
the stained glass windows changing and
stuff i'm glad that they put that in the
movie because i really liked that aspect
of the book they just did a good job of
just trying to keep the movie within the
boundaries of what this movie's supposed
to be you know i mean it's
it's a
it's a it's basically a harry potter but
it's
it was the original you know what i mean
yeah and it's to uh
it's got to be fun for the whole family
so they're working within a certain
framework yeah and i said it did it did
pretty good
yeah it was insane it was very charming
and fun and um you know and i really
like like i said i like that they had
the same vibe as the book i really like
the design of the house because it's
that's kind of what i was picturing they
added a few things to kind of like
modernize it or you know make it more in
line with you know why a fantasy of
nowadays so you know i get that they had
to do that and i like that there's some
stuff in there that's pretty scary i
mean the evil wizard is pretty scary i
mean he's a walking corpse pretty much
uh and he looks kind of [ __ ] up and um
you know so there's stuff in there about
world war ii a little bit
people whole families dying and [ __ ]
that's that kind of stuff in there and
then there's um in like the basement of
the house and i don't remember if this i
don't think this was in the original
book either but um there's like a room
of like all these like creepy mechanical
dolls and like robots and stuff and they
all come to life at some point and
that's like pretty creepy so i kind of
feel like if kids are really into horror
but you know are still too young to see
like real scary horror movies then this
is probably something and if i'd seen
this when i was a kid i'd have been all
over this [ __ ] holy crap
we saw the theater and enjoyed it yeah i
remember really liking it just you know
like like seeing ghostbusters or
something you know some are ghonies
gremlins [ __ ] like that
fourth drawer down said i wonder if this
is where stephen king got the idea for
the hedge animals well probably not
because i think the hedge animal was
only in this movie i don't remember the
hedge animal being in the book the book
came out in like 1973 like i said so
yeah it did predate the shining but
i don't i'm pretty sure the hedge
animals weren't in the book although i
could be wrong i need it's been a couple
years since i've reread the book uh mr
roboto says so jenny and tom what's the
deal with the clock the clock was
actually put there and like i said i'm
not sure if they're very super clear
with this in the movie but the clock was
put there by the evil wizard
to it's a doomsday clock when it stops
ticking or when it gets to midnight or
whatever the world will end
and so the evil wizard he just he did
that and then like he hid it in his
house and then he died
so when um so when jonathan took the
house over he kept hearing the clock but
he didn't know what the clock was for
but he knew that because isaac gizzard
had made it that it was probably
something really really bad and that
when it stopped ticking some really bad
[ __ ] was gonna happen he didn't know it
was like gonna be the end of the world
but so that's why like at the beginning
like one of the best early scenes is
when lewis first gets there and he hears
something like creaking around at night
and he goes down the hall and his
uncle's out there just like listening at
all the walls because he's looking to
see like where the clock is because he
knows he has to find it before
it before it strikes midnight or before
it's because it's i think it's like
i can't remember if the ticking is like
slowing down or speeding up i can't
remember what it was
but he knows he has to find it before
that even though he doesn't find out
until later until they find some of the
papers and everything like that like
what the clock actually does but it does
it will actually make the world end i
think that in the movie they specify
more that
um it's yeah it's the end of the world
but it's also that um
isaac wants to basically wipe everybody
off the earth so that him and his wife
selena will be the only people left so
they can like
run everything so they can like start
over we're gonna have to shut this down
i gotta go put the food away
yeah that's right yeah this is kind of
short i know but like i said we're gonna
go see dune
and so we gotta go get some candy and
get a drink and it's kind of a long
drive today and i can't leave movie
theater
and we have to go put the curry away so
we'll be back tomorrow talking about
dune because we're gonna go see it right
now so thanks everybody for dropping by
and we will see you guys tomorrow